good morning Hank it's Tuesday so what
if I told you that for Americans a
single data point can affect your life
expectancy more than whether you smoke
whether you get an annual physical or
whether you exercise regularly that data
point is your zip code the five digit
number the US Postal Service uses to
deliver your mail in the u.s. your zip
code can affect your life expectancy by
20 years and according to some recent
research the gap between the healthiest
communities and the sickest ones is
getting bigger so I live in the city of
Indianapolis and in my zip code life
expectancy is around 80 which is
slightly higher than the US average but
if you live three miles north of my
house average life expectancy rises to
83 point seven and if you live three
miles south of my house it falls to 69
point four now maybe that doesn't seem
like a big deal to you but just to put
it in some context on average
non-smokers in the u.s. live about ten
years longer than smokers people who
exercise regularly live about four point
five years longer than those who don't
and whether you live three miles north
or south of my house affects your life
expectancy by 14 years wait slight
tangent am I gonna spend all of those
extra four point five years exercising I
have to do some math okay so assuming
2.5 hours of moderate intensity exercise
per week beginning at the age of 16
you're gonna spend about one of your
extra years exercising then you're gonna
spend another 1.5 years sleeping you
basically get two extra years except of
course that's not how life expectancy
works if you a particular individual
exercise it doesn't mean that you're
particularly feuille be increased by
four point five extra years or even four
point five extra hours it just means
that on average that's what happens
similarly living in a particular zip
code doesn't mean a particular fate for
individuals but on average geography has
a huge impact on American health and
longevity so what's causing that
profound life expectancy gap well as
usual it's complicated like the Eastern
Kentucky communities where life
expectancy is under 70 have higher rates
of tobacco usage than the central
Colorado communities where life
expectancy is over 85 but Eastern
Kentucky is also poorer and has fewer
doctors communities with low life
expectancy tend to have less access to
healthy food and more uninsured people
people in those communities are also
more likely to have certain chronic
health problems like diabetes and
hypertension whereas the people in the
healthiest communities tend to be you
know rich
and have excellent access to health care
and the zip codes with the highest life
expectancy also tend to be in places
where there's lots of physical activity
like ski resorts in Colorado or wealthy
beach towns in California now I know too
many of us this is not surprising like
we take it for granted that rich people
will have dramatically longer and
healthier lives than poor people but
increasing inequality of life expectancy
within countries is not actually the
norm in fact while life expectancy
variability has been rising within the
US steadily since 1980 in most other
rich countries it's been declining
Canada for instance has seen a
significant decline which is one of the
main reasons why Canada's overall life
expectancy is higher than ours even
though the richest 20% of Americans live
longer on average than the richest 20%
of Canadians cite new lots of people
take issue with life expectancy as a
health metric especially when comparing
one country to another and with some
good reasons but the data we're
discussing here is mostly exempt from
those critiques much more info and
sources in the doobly-doo below right so
this growing discrepancy in life
expectancy is not normal and it is not
natural we don't have to accept that
lifespan will vary dramatically within a
country based on where you live but
right now in the United States that
problem is getting worse not better that
seems to me deeply wrong I mean our
Declaration of Independence famously
names three inalienable rights that
Americans should enjoy and before
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
there is life Hank I'll see you on
Friday actually no I will see you
tomorrow for a surprise bonus
vlogbrothers video and then I'll see you
on Friday